hi hey welcome to the monitor and you
welcomed me into the monitor let's meet
in the middle shall we and talk about
some pop culture in particular we can
talk about the trade addition of a
fantastic comic that gives you time to
catch up before it begins anew or we
could talk about a sneak release of a
new EP by one of my favorite bands but
why don't we start by talking about the
movie Argo directed by ben affleck who
has somehow become one of the best
directors working in Hollywood I can't
believe I just said those words out loud
but there you have it that's an official
pronouncement Gone Baby Gone was great
the town was great and this is his I
think the fourth movie he's directed
there was that one about George Reeves
man of steel but Argo is another Ben
Affleck joint to use the spike lee
parlance it is actually a story that
appeared in the pages of Wired a few
years ago and it is the tale of a number
of u.s. embassy workers who were kind of
on the run in Tehran after the the
embassy was stormed during the Iranian
Revolution in 1979 so the CIA sends over
this guy who's an exfiltration
specialist how is he going to get out
these u.s. embassy workers you ask
everyone knows what they look like well
he's going to disguise them for one and
he's going to smuggle them out under the
guise of being there scouting locations
for a movie that is essentially a
knockoff of Star Wars it sounds like one
of those things that would never happen
would only happen in a Hollywood movie
it did happen and it is also happening
in a Hollywood movie that's what she
called the one to the double shot uh-uh
sir mix-a-lot style however great
supporting cast I mean Ben Affleck is in
it he tends to put himself in his movies
which I'm okay with but also has a
fantastic supporting cast including the
wonderful John Goodman and the Wonder
fuller Alan Arkin it is it is
alternately tense and hilarious and it
takes place in Iran and it takes place
in in Hollywood and it is this kind of
fantastic story of
pulling off one of the biggest real life
lies uh that we know of and too
thrilling effect you should go see it
and I hope that this puts this on your
radar and we have a wonderful interview
with Sir Affleck who has not been
knighted but I am anointing him thus on
the monitor this week we have a great
interview with Ben Affleck in the
current issue of wired which is just
hitting stands now the october issue
with Kim com on the cover so make sure
you pick up not only wired but tickets
to our go music time I don't know why
I'm shaking my head like this and I
don't know why I'm singing but we are
going to talk about music and by we I
mean me and buy music I mean a new EP
from the stepkids which is kind of an
indie band that's signed two stones
throw and they are the trio that was
behind one of my very very very favorite
albums from last year the eponymous
album the stepkids at any rate they've
been touring for a good part of this
year but as they are putting the
finishing touches on their next album
which is supposed to drop early next
year they kind of snuck out this EP
which they're calling an EP but is
actually kind of like a glorified single
there are two real tracks on it sweet
salvation and bitter bug but sweet
salvation also has a remix on it and an
instrumental remix of it and an
instrumental of it and the video for
sweet salvation also dropped this week
done by their longtime collaborator and
light designer with crazy puppets as you
could probably see either behind me or
in front of me if I've disappeared in
here just watching the video with my
disembodied voice at any rate the step
kids are like if let's see well I guess
if holla notes was kidnapped by aliens
and then kind of had some sort of
genetic transfusion where they received
alien DNA and then hall and oates
spawned triplets and and and those three
people formed a band they kind of defy
categorization they are blue-eyed soul
mixed with a lot of futuristic fuzz and
I find them insanely listenable and
vastly entertaining and I think you will
too so pick that up that is a sweet
salvation EP from the stepkids out this
week back to you
alright comics this week now the Marvel
Universe relaunch had started last week
and continues on but I don't want to
talk about Marvel quite yet I want to
talk about the trade collection of an
image title called saga it is written by
Brian cave on the man behind great
series y the last man he was also a
writer on lost for a while and the
artist Fiona staples they have pledged
that they are going to work together
only the two of them on this series
throughout its entire run and Brian
Cavanaugh's stated that he wants us to
be his longest running series to date it
is the story of a couple one is from a
moon one is from the planet that that
moon revolves around and that planet and
that moon are embroiled in this horrible
civil war that is actually consumed the
entire galaxy with every planet and moon
pledging fealty to one side or the other
at any rate this is star-crossed love in
the most classic sense they have a
daughter and they are on the run they're
just trying to get to safety for the
sake of their daughter and for
themselves so you know they are it's a
parable for all sorts of things in this
day and age a lot of insane kind of
creatures and characters there is a
prince with a kind of computer monitor
for a head there's graphic sex can't be
too mad at that great writing is always
from Vaughn really wonderful humanizing
artwork from Fiona staples I really like
our style a lot the first six issues are
collected in the trade and it's not like
you're going to pick up this trade and
already have two or three more issues
that have come out the series has
actually been on hiatus for a month or
two and it's coming back in November so
now is the perfect time to get on board
get caught up six issues in one fell
swoop that is available hard copy that
is available digitally through image or
your favorite comics app so be sure to
pick that up that is it for the monitor
this week we will be back with more as
always email us at the monitor at
wired.com with anything you would like
to share including attachments but
though I can't promise I won't put them
in my trash folder if they are too
filthy for my delicate eyes but until we
see you next week inspiration
catchphrase here